this week's verses is a ruthless
slugfest and it comes courtesy of citta
gambrel heat Superman versus Shazam
first up is the big blue voiced out
better known as Superman the Man of
Steel fights for truth justice and the
American Way and he's conquered
countless foes in the process
challenging him for the win is the man
formerly known as Captain Marvel Shazam
the wizard infused Billy Batson with
godlike powers and transformed him into
one of the strongest beings on earth
Superman is unimaginably strong and fast
he's got superhuman senses and with no
need for food sleep or oxygen he can
take you down on land underwater or even
in space on a moment's notice but his
biggest asset might be good
old-fashioned tenacity he's taken a lot
of beatings but the Man of Steel always
lands on his feet with a single word
Shazam can match Clark's Kryptonian
might by taking on the wisdom strength
stamina power courage and speed of
anxious legends Titans and God but the
ace up his sleeve
is his ability to magically manipulate
electricity and attack his opponent with
powerful blasts of lightning from his
own body
Shazam powers are remarkable but there's
no intimidating the man of tomorrow in
2004 Superman Batman 13 Darkseid has
just taken out Supergirl so Clark punted
the evil overlord to the very edge of
outer space and trapped him in the
source wall when Supes unloads on an
opponent at full strength there's no one
who can't be Clark may have dominated
Darkseid one on one but Shazam already
has a win under his belt against the Man
of Steel in 1999 JLA number 29 he knocks
Superman out cold with an electric
one-two punch
Susanne's got the strength so he can
time his attacks right this battle won't
last long it's a well-known fact that
Superman is vulnerable to magic and
Shazam is powered by some of the most
powerful magic in the multiverse but
Clark is equally famous for flat-out
refusing to lose and
that kind of hood spot makes Shazam's
outlook cloudy at best Shazam's major
shortcoming is that he's just a boy in a
man's body and Superman will capitalize
on Phillies and experience but if
Captain Marvel can muster some maturity
he'll take down Superman faster than a
speeding bullet the stage is set which
hero would fly the W take the fight to
the comment section and let us know what
you think that's the battle for this
week so make sure you head down to the
comment and tell us who you think would
win and why plus we want to hear your
ideas like versus solely your dream
matchups in the comments below have a
great weekend and we'll see on Monday
Superfriends bye bye